yeah hello and welcome to this five
minute game on the roof is the opponent
from Tokyo and I'm trying out my reform
repertoire looking at Erika's a little
bit of a beverage Jimmy I have played
two games against him already I didn't
really remember one win one loss okay
I used one then he was talk to me from
the history find his black repertoire
books first I can't sell is he around
even had stuff to say I can ping him it
yeah he is wrong but you never know I
okay now he goes c5 and yeah playing c3
yeah this g3 line it's a rare line but I
think it's it's quite okay f5 Wow
interesting
hmm okay
what the heck 97 okay where are you
going he goes to g6 okay in this case I
actually would have preferred to have h4
h5 still with the rukon h1 but this is
also okay the way it is
does he really want to yeah he wants to
do this give me tons of development I
just wonder what is the right way to do
it we probably a.m.
I did not need to sacrifice this but it
was he provoked me enough to do it so
here if I check on age 5 he probably
drops back to her 7 and then the whole
thing doesn't really it doesn't really
do all that much I'm sure there 496 can
also just take I mean the advantage is
that I'm his castling rights are spoiled
and chess might be a good idea actually
I'm getting more development doing maybe
one next and potentially 95 okay so if I
play rook d1
I wonder which I think this one might
check this is more of a gut feeling that
anything else
okay Knight b5 now is an idea definitely
trying to get to the roof immediately
what I can move the bishop again but I
don't really have all that great squares
Knight Bishop g5 yummy BM I don't really
like to let him take if he goes Bishop
e7 I go Bishop e3 I still have not b5
which is tough to meet my compensation
he is not not like I mean that I'm
checkmating him quickly or so it I have
quite substantial pressure on the Queen
side so I think night b5 here just
attacking this on a 697 I'm just winning
stuff rook b8 Bishop e7 the rook is
entirely trapped this also looks rather
uncomfortable to meet okay so 97 he
intends to do what we'll see
maybe he thought our idea was just to
take on a seven
hmm yeah that's just Vince material
and it's a full rock I think I've I if
he goes Bishop d7 I think 80 cannot
recapture as the bishop hangs the two
white bishop CR doing a pretty good job
yeah I think it's it's just gone not
entirely sure I should have sacrificed
the pawn I mean I can have a great
position just without taking a pawn I
mean it worked out fine obviously but
not sure about the objective merit of
the sacrifice I don't quite see what the
point of all this is just resigned them
letting the clock run down I mean it
doesn't take two minutes to figure out
that you have no move
yep doesn't move
black forfeits on time yeah cannot
expect much some people are really weird
okay so pretty
normal opening any plate f5 which I
don't think it's all that great yeah
I mean you have to you know you don't
have to it the move d6 attacking the
white pawn is very natural and if you
play a five that that is difficult to do
yeah I know is losing time with all this
yeah probably
probably I shouldn't go d5 and just play
Knight c3 as the engine suggests I mean
I must have compensation but I probably
can can play without this and and my
position is just as good even though the
engine quite quickly shows a substantial
edge for white yeah yeah this is care
Queen e2 it makes perfect sense actually
[Music]
check here I have compensation as well
but keep Shaq wins on mix makes more
sense this issue is oops should be three
check would you like to see if he has
something here so yeah Bishop d7 Miriam
offering b7 yeah this is quite okay for
him yeah this is quite okay for him
obviously yeah this this is not all that
convincing probably I mean Queen e2 is
stronger here you know it does not have
this move because there is also Changi v
check winning the bishop yeah that was
much stronger than the
changuk aperture check yeah I can
probably improve bishop c7 mm-hmm well
wishers yourself yeah it's certainly
good compensation but here if he goes
Bishop d7 instead of king f7 he's okay
yeah and here this is already very very
difficult this news is in the house but
rook b8 given by the engine which is not
a very human move I think I probably
would have just taken this even though
that it's not the best or what the
engine is giving now you just cannot
develop this anymore with the King here
d7 is unprotected yeah it's not fun it's
not funny at all I think what you should
do is just not play a 5 that is not a
good move here ok guys thanks for
watching